oh he's going on YouTube check it out
see now I know a lot of y'all leave a
lot of messages and stuff in my inbox
asking to do different topics and guess
what I'll read them so one subscriber
ash how you get over your x-men when you
when you love them so much first off get
your [ __ ] [ __ ] together getting over
somebody isn't easy you don't watch
because a lot of people will give you
[ __ ] advice so you already know what
is LG I bet let's get it out number one
a lot of you jackasses will tell your
friends just remember the good times
buddy it'll make the moving on process a
lot easier
yeah that is the dumbest [ __ ] thing
I've ever heard shut up this is my
personal philosophy and you don't have
to take it if you are going to
constantly remember the good times you
had with that person you are not gonna
get over there how she would tickle my
double chin the way she kissed me the
way she used to rub my belly no to hell
with that remember all the messed up
[ __ ] she did to you remember that time
you farted in front of her and she will
not stop laughing at you for months that
she went off and told all of her friends
and now everybody knows you as kimchi
farts Hey
remember that one time she smacked you
so hard she rearranged your face like a
mr. Potato Head [ __ ] number two after
you get dumped step your game up player
there is no such thing as seeing your
girl the next day like everything's okay
after she tore out your heart
oh my god just could spit about how you
been come here [ __ ] you broken heart
you gotta make sure she regrets leaving
your pathetic ass cuz the next time she
sees you walking down the street you
better make sure she regrets leaving the
best thing she ever had not a drink
later oh my god David evict you you look
really good huh what was that word oh I
didn't see you there yeah I've been
working on XP in the gym i'ma just be
chillin over here I'm number three stop
thinking that the first person you fall
in love with is going to be it for you
do you have any idea how rare that [ __ ]
is I know one married couple right now
that have been together since they were
like in seventh grade and let me tell
you something I hate their guts
I'm just being hate I'm playing I love
them very much but what they have is an
exception to the rule the reality of it
is when you're young you don't know who
you are or what you want so as you get
older things change against what people
change too if I was still with the girl
that I fell in love with today I would
still be with Wendy's that's right the
burger joint
cuz she was open 24/7 you don't fade aha
yeah yeah I had to do a joke on number
fo stop trying to be friends with your
ex right after you break up idiot you
can't be friends with them right after a
period end of story
the only reason why you want to be
friends with an actor is so hopefully
one day they might change their mind and
come crawl to my back to you well guess
what the [ __ ] don't watch no more now
leave her I'm not saying that there are
stories later on people get back
together but adds up the moment you need
to pack your [ __ ] and bounce and you
know what women you're at fault too
because you need to stop saying [ __ ]
like oh my god let's just be friends
after this we're better as friends [ __ ]
and II stopped home with my heart cut
your ties move on and then maybe in the
future you guys could be friends but as
at the moment it's not gonna happen just
farted and I just catch it with the
[ __ ] myself oh my god oh my god here
it is if you want to learn how to move
on from somebody you got to make the
conscious choice to do so you got to
realize something there are a million
people out there and then she's not the
one for you then you're just wasting
your time on something that's not gonna
have
pick your sorry self up and use that
energy and finding the person that's
going to appreciate you there are a lot
of things in this world that really
aren't gonna work out the way you wanted
to that's just how life is you gotta
roll with the punches
here's the funny thing about me I think
I have my very first girlfriend at the
age of like 17 or something like that it
was really late with it big girl I fell
in love with like I was mad in love with
her she broke my heart she dumped me
here that's off and on thing after we
broke up for like another year too and
guess what I wasted all that time and
now look at me look at me
you don't want to be like this this is
scary you're a strength move on but you
gonna end up you know sad and [ __ ] all
by yourself talking to a camera in the
room for a living even if later on
tonight I ask you to be my girlfriend
right she's not the one for you and
you're wasting your time on her guess
what the one out there that's really for
you what am I saying